First Republic Bank has been taken over
by federal regulators and will be sold
to JPMorgan making it the third major
Bank to go under in less than two months
within 200 with 229 billion dollars in
total assets at the time of closure
First Republic Bank has become the
second largest bank failure in American
history 90 days apart by the way losing
about 40 percent of its deposit in the
first quarter of the Year amid Rising
interest rates and after the failure of
Silicon Valley Bank and Signature Bank
earlier this year causing a growing
cohort of depositors to move their money
to Banks seen as safer and offering more
attractive returns as of mid-march about
70 percent of First Republic deposits
were uninsured that's that's a big
number meaning they were larger than 250
000 guaranteed limit the FDIC estimates
the cost of first Republic receivership
will be about 13 million dollars less
than the 20 billion dollars that is
estimated at the cost of Silicon Valley
Bank First Republic's 84 branches and
eight states will reopen Monday as
branches of JPMorgan Chase Tom
well you know some of you may walk down
the street and quaint little towns and
you'll notice a garage sale and you go
up maybe buy a trinket get lucky find an
old baseball card there uh Jamie Diamond
on the weekend walks down the street and
buys Banks and this case
there's First Republic do you take a
check
um the and what is happening here is the
consolidation of of the banking industry
because ever since 2008 the last crisis
things have become more and more lacks
you know you've had a variety of things
that have glass-steagall and other
things that were designed to help it but
now you have Banks failing except the
FDIC think of that as the deductible
like when your car crashes you 500
deductible at the body shop and then the
other guy that crashed into you
hopefully their insurance pays the rest
well the FDIC a little sticker on the
window that says 250 000 deposit think
of that as the deductible but now Jan
and Yellen when svb crashed they created
that new vehicle that the banks can get
their hands on which protects 250
thousand dollars and up so it basically
goes like this it it promotes your
responsibility because now the banks can
be very irresponsible because FDIC will
get part Janet Yellen and treasury will
get the other part and then the bank
will get bought because there's loans in
there there's car loans home loans with
good people and things and JP Morgan
says I'll take those loans over here
I'll collect the interest on them and
I'll help you out and so what is
happening is a consolidation of banking
and then unstable banks are are failing
um this is also is very interesting as
svb and First Republic
JP Morgan specifically Jamie dimon is
trying to walk back into Silicon Valley
to have a foothold there remember this
2016 he was the first of the big Banks
and he came out in a annual banking
letter and he said listen Silicon Valley
is coming they're smart they're clever
they're going to take away consumer pain
points and they're not going away and
they don't take prisoners so he was
warning the traditional banking industry
of basically the looming fintech and
he's trying to come back in and make
himself
um you know relevant make JPMorgan
relevant three years later he says oh
you know um I just want to let you know
Chase is not a tourist we're not just
visiting he's not a lecture tour that
we're doing here in Silicon Valley we're
here and we want to do things and so
you're basically seeing Chase
saying it wants to be the biggest and
they're they're not I respect that I do
listen Sandy Weil had a chance when the
whole story when you know uh Jamie
Diamond used to work for Sandy wow Sandy
told Jamie do whatever you want to do
run the company the first thing is Jamie
Diamond does is fires his daughter it's
a very wild story and then the wife says
what are you doing fire your daughter I
said you can't fire my daughter he says
you told me to run the company he used
to be a city guy so everybody knows in
that world if you're gonna talk about
the Michael the Kobe of this era Jamie's
the guy and he's not slowing down
and he's going to be a guy that when
you're thinking about someone's going to
be a you know company to buy everybody
points at Jaime so he's done a great job
you got to give him credit but the
question now becomes
quietly as much as they want to downplay
this how many people are now sitting
there saying listen man I'm not waiting
anymore we're part of a regional we're
part of a community we're leaving just
go to one of the big five this is two in
90 days or 120 days we're not talking
about like 20 billion dollar bank or 40.
these are two 200 billion dollar Banks
we're talking about 200 you know how big
200 billion is if you were to look at
some of the companies that we all know
about Starbucks size if you go to you
know Coca-Cola if somebody's coming how
big are these companies these are 200
billion dollar companies there's not
that many 200 billion dollar companies
that we're talking about Tom who's next
based on this who are they talking about
I've heard couple different names I'm
curious to know who you hearing about
being possible I wish I had the whole
list in front of me but it's basically
there's a variety of lists out there is
and there's some ones that are right at
the top that are stretched on on the
loans they made and
the things that they invested in they
invested some bonds which are now have
moved on the interest rate meaning
picture it this way Banks bought I'll
put it this way for gold for the average
person understand they bought gold high
now Gold's low and they can't have
having trouble selling the gold and
that's supposed to offset the loans they
have so it's like whoops you now can't
sell the gold to pay off all all your
loans or to cover all your loans what's
for every there's another very very
interesting thing that's going on in the
middle of this is what you just said Pat
Goldman came out and they had a crappy
earnings quarter but
they had a whole bunch more deposits now
where did that come from of course
Schwab came out and had actually a solid
quarter but they got a bunch more
deposits and Schwab was saying you know
we were very surprised Schwab has a
money fund that's right around four
percent and that's fairly low risk like
the lowest risk you can get is like a
standard money fund four percent may not
seem like a lot until until you think
back that Ma and Pa have been looking at
interest rates of half a percent one
percent or nothing and all of a sudden
money's being moved to money markets
say hey Mom Mom and Paul talk about it
they say well at least we can get four
percent and we're not exposed to this
zaniness going on in the stock market so
if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]